if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps
dumps
[Music]
dumps
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
look at that
look at that look at that batman's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
censorship d banking arrest tyranny
corporate takeover censorship d banking
harass tyranny
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
harass tyranny
look at that
look at that
corporate takeover censorship d banking
harass tyranny look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser and he's a
disgrace and he's in his christ
and he's in this christ and he's a
disgrace
[Music]
is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is a baby
david patman
he is a man
of david pakman
he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on we would everything
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male died but
another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman obama
david pacman
he is a man
david pakman
he is a
[Music]
[Music]
david patman he is a baby
david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman
he is
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're asking like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're acting like
you're an idiot and you're wasting my
time i appreciate that coming all right
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
they are weak people and why haven't it
doesn't even
[Music]
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
[Music]
bathrooms
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures
eight or 11 bucks
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
is
[Music]
well welcome everybody it is a second
consecutive stream as i promised
yesterday we did the thing i said
arbitrarily we had to do for me to be
here again
and i'm here
and i'm here with my glasses there's no
honestly
these are just there there's not even
these aren't even prescription i look at
my finger goes right through it see that
whoops oh hold on
now anyway these are real oh god now i
can't even see straight hold on
what is on these things all right
we're gonna get it figured out
the glasses are real
the glasses are real
uh i've i'm hassan guys i've gotta wear
the glasses now to do the thing okay
it is a trump rally and i believe it is
extremely likely
that this is the most dangerous
the most unhinged and the most
disturbing rally
for a long time why do i say that
well i say it because at last night's
january 6 committee hearings
there were
humiliating outtakes played of donald
trump visibly struggling with just
telling the truth
in his post riot video totally
humiliating he went on his um
social media platform i guess uh we call
it uh let's see if i even have the name
of it here truth essential yeah trump
went on truth central
and just completely lost it as this
video was playing yesterday and then
today steve bannon was convicted
so
it is
i i can only imagine he is going to lose
his mind
he will certainly do his thing where he
says teachers shouldn't be allowed to
teach transgender we still don't even
know what that means
but he's going to say it
that's uh that's that's one of his
classic go-to's now so it's going to be
absolutely and completely nuts and i'm
so glad that you're with me today and
trump is expected to speak relatively
soon and we have so many things to talk
about between now and then
first and foremost
at the top of yesterday's stream i
announced an initiative okay
and we will ban men
no that would be idiotic we're just
doing a new channel we're going to be
doing by popular demand a personal
finance channel many people don't know
this people assume my background is in
pediatrics and it's not my background is
actually in financial planning and
occasionally i will get questions about
personal finance on the show
and it's really
meaty and thick
and it stands on its own so we are by
popular demand and because producer pat
convinced me to do it we are going to be
creating a new personal finance only
channel it will be completely unrelated
and parallel to the political content
and it's going to be great and what i
asked you all was give me some ideas for
names
okay
let's see if i can somehow pull this up
uh maybe i'll do like a little notepad
yeah here we go here are the names that
you guys sent to me
so far
and if people have more ideas you can
send them in here's what has been
proposed so far and we're taking
suggestions for this channel
i'm basically going to be the sane
pro-vaccine alternative to dave ramsey
that's kind of the gist of it okay
here's some ideas pac-man finance pac-fi
pac-money on the money money clip
money matters money talks
not financial advice bankruptcy data
from a beta pay yourself first bulls
bears and betas all money matters
everybody relax finance the monetary
report a play on stealing sam sader's
the majority report a penny a day with
david pakman the next nest egg
elements of finance money according to
pacman finance with david pakman
freenance the coin purse the david
cashman show with david pakman making
sense with david pakman callers and
cents
david pakman's dollar facts man
pacmanomics basic pakmenomics
david's bagels and economics money talks
unpacking finances
from the standpoint of finance
the money show with david pakman and
friends finance with fact man the david
finance man show it's money time sir
sure sure jerry
sir sir sir okay millions and millions
and millions
pacman's pecuniary punditry dollars and
cents pac monopoly pacman pennies
saving coin okay you guys get it all
right there's just a lot of these these
options
if you have better ideas
email info davidpakman.com
always always open to more ideas
no decision has yet been made
first super chat michael says hey david
sawyer were made a meme
on
yms jurassic world dominion at 4 55.
man i don't know what that means let's
see if we can find that
but anybody know what that means is that
some kind of code for something
let's see why ms resico dominion
at 455
your movie sucks.org
dominion
all right let's see if we can find that
is it this let's see 455.
four
here we go dinosaur
would be like the joker he said that the
dinosaur is like the joker what in sweet
[ __ ] giga cringe oh there it is okay
that's pretty cool all right i'll take
that
i'll take that
progressive values with david pakman or
david pakman's progressive values that
doesn't sound anything like a finance
channel that sounds like a political
channel that's the only issue with that
one
beta bucks oh damn that's pretty good
beta bucks with professor pakman milo
please email that in
beta bucks with professor pakman that's
really not bad
i could see myself going for that
okay so we've dealt with that and i'm uh
oh excited to to hear more ideas from
you guys
next thing
many of you may know i am not big on
cats i'm just
not a big fan of cats oh hold on a
second
we already there's there's uh
anti-semitic suggestions being made for
the finance channel
which is not surprising but it's an
insta-ban
instant ban okay as many of you know
i am not a big fan of cats i like dogs
uh
oh hold on more anti-semitic ones it's
just an insta-ban they're all moderators
all anti-semitic uh
suggestions for the finance channel just
banned no no warning or anything okay
so anyway i like dogs i like babies not
not a big fan of cats but
one of our good friends from twitch
on the streams is a user who goes by the
name small fuzzy moss
small fuzzy moss is actually responsible
for a whole bunch of the drops that i
play on the show we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
obama and we will ban men hatman's a
loser we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel
sure
sure
okay anyway so small fuzzy moss sent me
this video
her cat
loves the show
and
specifically reacts to my face and
starts scratching at my face check this
out this is this is pretty
this is pretty good
look at the cats
very closely examining me
all right so that's a nice cat
that kind of i also like the
pp poopoo mug
that's a nice touch small
the peepee poopoo mug
filled with uh
pencils and pens all right
well let's continue
adam gingrich says keep up the good work
sir thank you adam and thank you for all
the generous gifts of subscriptions that
you've done appreciate it
chandra says would the new show
interfere with the political show no
the new show will not interfere with the
political show whatsoever not even one
iota okay
thank you very much let's say thank you
to a few people robo blake liquid ice
robbie my bag of mangoes rhino blueberry
babe
beth graham monotone mark shoplifting
empath
have all grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions
i really appreciate that also big thank
you to kevin gouldy who just gifted a
subscription through my website
joinpakman.com kevin you're the man
we love that
david sir how likely do you think it is
gavin newsom runs in 24 i think it's
quite likely well he may not be a bernie
it would be nice to get someone younger
you know someone younger than their 70s
oh
i have already said i think gavin newsom
is an excellent politician i'm not
saying he's my favorite on policy
but we need skilled politicians
gavin newsom ranted and raved the other
day about how like why is the left on
defense all the time
sorry i froze there why is the left on
defense all the time
we're always playing d and and he's like
the left has to be ruthless the left has
to be on offense i agree with him a
thousand percent
i'm very interested
in gavin newsom
i think pete budege is also a highly
skilled politician i think that would be
fantastic uh i mean listen i'm not
saying these people can all win
but i think boot edge edge brings
exactly the type of uh
offense that we need i mean quite
frankly
and it is what it is all right so we'll
have more time to talk about it
uh how about a cooking channel instead
of a personal finance channel
specifically carrot focused recipes i
don't see that happening craig or finley
finley craig craig findlay
uh that's not currently in the cards
okay
let's take a look at one of the reasons
that trump is going to be
bigly triglete tonight which is that
last night the following outtakes were
made a central moment of the january
sixth committee hearing these were
this is trump
trying to record
his actually is there a better no this
one's fine um trying to record a speech
to the writers
and hold on a second where the hell are
we going here
okay here we go
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
and to those who broke the law
you will pay
you do not represent our movement you do
not represent our country
and if you broke the law
you can't say that
i'm not you i already said you will pay
yep he's not going to go after the
rioters that hard guys what do you think
he's going to really condemn them that's
crazy
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defied the seat of destiny it's
defiled right see i can't see it very
well okay i'll do this i'm going to do
this let's go no more dropbox the
dropbox rhino named mitt romney maxill
cohen i've had more investigations than
jesse james billy that could okay
but this election is now over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election's over no
the election's over that sounds like you
lost and god bless
the united states truth essential
tender
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
right
congress
now congress yeah right now congress i
didn't say over so let me say
don't go to the paragraph before
okay
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday yesterday's a
hard word for me
obama
ah good take the word yesterday because
it doesn't work with yep trump's also a
tough word for him then he went donald
trump yeah donald trump
henry's attack
on our country say on our country
want to say that no no
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
oh man
so anyway it was not a great day for
scrumps yesterday and so we're expecting
maybe the most triggered trump we've
ever seen today at the rally and also
steve bannon was indicted
just all sorts of problems for trump
over the last uh 24 hours really really
really bad so we're i mean i'm looking
forward to it to be perfectly frank
let's look at some other super chats
here keep up the good work sir okay we
did that one
did this one warnock ayock 2024 ticket
winner zero chance that that's the
ticket david i'm a member and iranian
living in canada in a future video i
would like to hear your take on biden's
failure on jcpoa talks all right i will
be
heading up to canada very soon i will be
inside canada for a pretty strong period
of time actually it's going to be an
interesting
interesting trip
do you think the members of the
committee are saving information for an
october surprise god i hope so
serious message i think the outtakes of
trump shows clearly how he goes in and
out of his maga character what are your
thoughts no i don't think so
i mean he seems to be in character the
entire time right or maybe am i seeing
that incorrectly what do people in chat
think
to me it seemed like it was not a
character
sadly i guess
mangoes and money is another suggestion
sir my lawyer and i are playing trump
bingo tonight do you think trump will
announce his run for 24 tonight
i would ordinarily say there's no chance
trump announces that tonight but
my expectation is he's going to be so
triggered from the outtakes and bannon
being found guilty and all of this stuff
maybe he will announce i don't know
carmen sends five bucks for the diaper
fund thank you carmen
appreciate that
um all right and we are standing by now
oh i don't even know if i want to do
this
do you guys want to hear about something
kind of
horrible that some people on the left
have done
to me they've victimized
me really a victim but it's just one of
these bummers where i'm like oh god are
we this screwed on the left do you want
to hear about this or do we want to not
do we want to keep it positive
people want to hear it okay
so listen here's the deal
i am not a democrat
i could not care less about the
democratic party
i just want
policy
that's better for people
i'm on the left
if the democrats the better option
i'll vote for the democrat but i don't
care about the democratic party
and i don't really care about
centrists and i don't it just it's just
i just don't care i just tell you guys
what i think you know that's it it's
really that simple
and i also
tell you all the truth
and one of the truths right now
is that
joe biden's approval
is lower than it's been his entire
presidency
now
we cover
presidential politics
presidential approval is a story
we covered
george w bush's
approval rating
we covered obama's approval rating obama
we right we covered
trump's approval rating
and i cover joe biden's approval rating
so like
i talk about approval
i also i'm not going to lie to you
right now
joe biden's approval is at a record low
an average of 37.4 percent
so
today we published a story called joe
biden approval again hits record low
right i mean he hit a record low here
and then another one here and then
another one here and then another one
here another one here
and i even go through in the clip
and i compare
biden's approval to other presidents
these aren't my opinions right do people
understand
these aren't my opinions that this is
polling like is that clear
people get that okay so like trump had a
higher approval right now
obama had a higher approval right now
obama george w bush had a higher
approval all these presidents had you
can go back to john f kennedy so
i reported what's going on
i got
so many
long time
members who wrote to me and said
what dave one one guy wrote what david
are you mad joe biden didn't give
everybody a pony what kind of a story
was that you shouldn't be doing that
story
the hell out of here what who are you
i'm supposed to hide
that biden's approval is in the toilet
and that nothing's happening that
who benefits from me doing that
how dare i discuss facts about joe biden
so
this is
i mean guys
instead of being angry
that i communicated the truth about
biden's bad approval rating
what if we figure out like maybe how to
win the midterms and get something done
and
figure out how to not get crushed in
2024 i i mean it's
it's absolutely insane
it's really like a kill the messenger
sort of thing
so
extremely disappointed to see that and
like listen it's easy to say well david
you're mad because people are cancelling
paid memberships yeah i mean i think
that it's another one of these instances
where like how do we win on the left
if someone says
hey uh
the guy in office isn't doing so hot in
the approval and you go i'm pulling my
money now because you said that no we
should be saying wow thanks for letting
us know that this guy's not doing well
we've got to fix that
it is it's bad guys it's bad
really really bad
so anyway extraordinarily disappointing
to see that and like listen if you're
canceling your membership because i told
you biden's not super popular
at some point you were gonna bail for
some stupid reason anyway so so like you
know we're kind of
we're getting some weak hands uh off the
table i guess is what you know what
we're gonna say
but very disappointing to see and again
it's like how are we gonna win if that's
so triggering to people biden's approval
here's a fact it's from gallup just a
poll okay so let's move on that's it
um
why are you reporting the suppression
balls right they're suppression polls
exactly
um yeah okay so people appreciate
hearing that that's good uh i'm glad
people are
people are responding thanks to
bernadette affects robbie
margot cabot
for the twitch prime subscriptions that
puts us at 12 very much appreciate that
also want to say thanks to martin
phillian who just gifted a subscription
at joinedpakman.com listen if you want
to replace some of these people who quit
who rage quit
the equivalent of pooping in the sandbox
because i mentioned biden's approval uh
head on over to joinpakman.com we have a
coupon code today the code is indict
it's spelled like indict you have to
please i know we have to spell it
correctly
you can use the coupon code at
joinpakman.com
it gives you a beautiful discount look
at this indict
boom and extra secret code if you want
to use the code obama obama
it's actually even more criminal what it
does
you can use the code mango as well i
don't know if we have a code mango
actually
not sure about that
not sure about that
uh david sir are you still going on
patrick bet david's podcast they're in
desperate need of a genuine progressive
perspective next time i'm in that area i
will do it if patrick will have me i
hope to be able to reschedule that soon
putin's disadvantage was not wanting an
accurate assessment so you are right to
share an accurate assessment of actual
news keep it up pacman thank you
monolith i appreciate that hey david
thanks for the hard work you do can you
give us a quick billy the cud absolutely
i've had more investigations than jesse
james billy they could yeah i expect
that tonight's um
presentation from scrumps is going to
fill the sound board phil
of intricacy a combination of finance
and intricacy by the way are
right-wingers fine with for example
muslims having free access to firearms
asking from germany
massive dumps of love from here that be
a question for the gun people
i would ask them
i would ask them
it's not your fault biden's approval
resides in the third element of the
bathroom right you've got three elements
in the bathroom you've got your sink
you've got
your shower
and then you've got the third element
elements of bathrooms exactly right
what are your thoughts on michael
cohen's view that trump has no interest
in running in 24 and will be a king
maker instead so i've spoken michael
cohen by the way is a friend of the show
good guy i've talked to michael off air
uh he's just an all-around good guy he's
he's shouted me out on his podcast
he we just disagree he says trump won't
run because trump can't stand losing
i believe trump's going to be i believe
michael cohen is correct that trump
can't stand the idea of losing but i
think trump's going to come away
thinking he can win
and i believe he will run
uh dollars with david or david talks
dollars all right we're only taking
submissions via email remember ryan
david there was a knock on my door and
today today and apparently i am being
subpoenaed to appear at court for a
trial between mike pilot and my cpap
machine almost beautifully executed mr
feeney not quite but very very close to
beautifully executed i love that all
right let's uh do you guys want okay
i'll give you an option
do you want to do voicemails or do you
want to look at trump's diarrhea of the
of the post on truth central where he
was just out of control
what do people want
btc did a shout out in a stream where
he's wearing the green hoodie
insane girl what are you talking about
there brian tyler cohen has one of my
hoodies
or what are you talking about
i haven't seen that i don't even know
that i understand your message on twitch
btc did a shout out with the green
hoodie my green hoodie
or cohens
all right well let me know insane girl
that'd be cool to check out i would
thank him for that but i don't know
no he was wearing a hoodie in a stream
it was a shout out to good channels to
watch
oh
and did he mention my channel or michael
cohen's i'm so confused insane iamgirl
this is crazy
anyway if someone find a clip whatever
it is if if if it's self-referential
then we always want to shout those
people out let me know i don't know what
the hell is going on all right let's
look at truth central yesterday donald
trump went bonkers on truth central
let's see if we can find the posts from
yesterday
um
actually it's sort of been all day just
posting clip after clip after clip
various videos promoting the rally
trump maintains a commanding lead he's
not even running right now
random he's spending his entire day
posting on truth
the president's not in the military he's
the commander-in-chief he's a civilian
quoting john dean
just meaningless meaningless attempts
meaningless attempts
to
use language to communicate meaning
is this the same mitch mcconnell who was
losing big in kentucky and came to the
white house to beg me for an endorsement
and help without me he would have lost
in a landslide a disloyal sleaze bag
okay
i had an election rigged and stolen from
me in our country the usa is going to
hell am i supposed to be happy oh man i
need like a i need like a sad tuba
sound effect or something for that
what would i even
need something like that right am i
supposed to be happy
it's nancy pelosi's fault she turned
down the troops perhaps she was
disengaged maybe looking for her husband
so that's untrue there's no evidence
trump requested troops and there's no
evidence that nancy pelosi blocked them
or turned them down it's just made up
fake tapper of cnn is so biased and
pathetic no wonder cnn's ratings are at
an all-time low
ps almost all trump endorsed candidates
have won or are winning
liz cheney is a sanctimonious loser the
great state of wyoming is wise to her
why not show the tapes or interview
those that with evidence challenge the
election
one but crooked hillary and stacey
abrams and many others contested their
elections far longer than i
did hillary clinton contest the results
of 2016 for two years i just don't
remember that did that happen
i have no memory of that
that i don't know what he's talking
about
two how do they know i watched on tv
three i never said that to kevin
mccarthy who came to mar-a-lago to say
hi
wasn't this the same sarah matthews who
i don't know that said such nice things
about me on january 20th
why haven't the unselects asked for
secret service corroboration of the
so-called chokehold because they know
the answer and don't like it you know
it's funny the um
the day oh hey welcome everybody rating
from grand master benjamin feingold
benjamin feingold with a newly high
chess rating which we celebrate here we
love to see it
welcome everybody coming from ben's
stream we're getting we're looking at
truth central and soon trump's going to
be speaking and it's going to be bonkers
okay so stand by welcome everybody you'd
love to see it
um
after cassidy hutchinson testified about
all the things she saw see happened with
secret service
off the record a bunch of secret service
agents were like i'll testify under oath
i'll testify under oath and the people
from the january 6 committee said great
come on in
and then they never did
it's
you know so anyway you can see just all
day and night
trump posting to truth central and it's
pathetic and i don't even have anything
else to say about it okay thank you very
much
um
[Music]
thank you to peripheral rose
irie man and edgeworth for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 16.
folks i do want to mention
um there are let me see if i even have
these here
do i have my right
element
big massive dumps i do
huge dumps of memberships coming in on
the website mark van daan is a new
member
uh
jason rhodes is a new member andy
steineke is a new member
jamie ramirez is a new member andy
ringen is a new member
che arbizu is a new member kim berklin
ward is a new member
mark miller has just signed up daniel
hughes is a new member esther barasa has
signed up carolyn corposic new member
neil srivastava
has signed up
that's 14 okay 14 16 4 and 6 is 10-0
carry the 1 1 1 1 is 3. that's 30.
and then a bunch of people gifting
subscriptions i can't even thank all of
them because there's so many one
two
three
four
four gifted subscriptions at
joinpackman.com
really appreciate that if you're just
joining us we're standing by for the
rally we have a coupon code indict
i would love it if you signed up at join
i will thank everybody to my the best of
my ability also thanks to beans and
weens for the twitch prime subscription
all right let's go to a few voicemails
we don't want to miss
what's happening on the voicemail line
let's listen
hey david i think your next promo code
should be
yesterday
uh
it might limit your audience a little
bit though
right
right
david sir are you ever going to address
the criminally low
subscription rates to hear your bonus
show that i keep hearing about yeah
sounds very illegal we're uh currently
the evidence is in front of a grand jury
really to decide whether there's when i
do these huge discounts like with coupon
code indict
uh and and these are like
huge huge huge discounts okay huge when
i do these
a grand jury is looking at whether i had
a guilty mind when i did it like did i
do it knowing it was against the law or
did i just want to offer people a good
deal
and it wouldn't be appropriate for me
much like steve bannon didn't tamper
with the uh
jury in his trial
i'm not gonna get involved in that right
now okay
let's see what else we've got
david sir as someone that is a former
trump supporter i
stopped supporting him before january 6
it's really eye-opening to me now to
to see these hearings i knew that day
was bad i did not know it was this bad
uh yesterday's hearing was
extremely disturbing all of them have i
did not know
what exactly was going on
um
and it
it it makes me sick to my stomach that i
could ever support wow a man like that
and i'm glad that i finally
saw the light and
left
that cult
thank you wow
well one of the things we've been
wondering is whether anyone is seeing
the january 6 committee who actually
needs to see it and it sounds like the
answer is sort of yes sort of yes here's
an interesting question
jose asks sir congratulations on the
addition to your family
thoughts on cloth diapers versus single
use for both massive and non-massive
dumps so here's the deal
we are exclusively on single use
landfill
stuffing
disposable diapers and i'm gonna tell
you why and then you yeah we're get they
they're ending yeah guys i know so
they're switching over to
um
the first gold group can
do just that and help you out so we're
fine we've got multiple streams we've
got this stream we've got all these
different streams everybody relax please
i've got it under control
we are exclusively on single use rather
than cloth diapers and i know a couple
of people who sort of look down they
they look down their nose and be and you
know it was all very woke and they said
oh sir how can you do this to the planet
and all these different things
so i investigated the issue
in depth
i'm putting aside whether i really want
to be running baby crap through my
washing machine okay so i'm putting that
i'm saying i'm tabling that issue
it is an issue believe me but i'm
tabling the issue for now okay
number one
uh cloth diapers made from cotton
cotton's a disaster
okay cotton when the amount of water
that cotton needs
uh cotton is not as eco-friendly as some
people think they're like well polyester
you know you've got the fossil fuels
sure
cotton not so good okay so cotton
diapers i'm not big on that next issue
when you are
washing
these cloth diapers
you have to do it at a very high
temperature
and not only is the there the
electricity
for the washing machine itself you've
also got the electricity of the
wash the hot water heater so now i'm
starting to think like okay am i really
coming out ahead with this thing or not
but
there's no way in hell i'm washing these
things myself
i'm not i'm not running baby crap in my
clothes washer are you nuts
so
by the way tankless water heaters still
have to heat the water it's just a
different mechanism okay so then
everybody's like you get a service oh
wait so now
you've got trucks driving around burning
fuel
in order to
drive the dirty diapers around and then
they go into these
industrial
high temperature washing machines
and then you drive them back come on
guys it was not at all obvious that it
was the the the greener choice to me
and
it's certainly a nightmare
it's certainly a nightmare so no i am on
single-use diapers
and uh i'm incinerate incinerating
everything on my roof also so that's
that's we're releasing the methane into
the atmosphere but we're just
incinerating everything so it's a
beautiful thing okay let's listen to a
couple others
hi david i'm calling for financial
advice i know your show hasn't started
yet but i'm hoping maybe you can make
this uh in your first segment so i
donated a million dollars to steve
bannon's
wall fund um i'm just wondering if i
should donate another million to that
fund or maybe i should go to
uh trump stakes maybe invest in that or
or should i just go back to school to
trump university
yeah those are not exactly the types of
questions we'll be answering on the uh
personal finance channel so that that's
that the caliber of that question is low
very very very low and we're not going
to be dealing with that okay
um let's see what else we've got
brian tyler cohen urges his followers on
his streams to also financially support
other progressive youtubers and mentions
you kyle sam etc that's all thank you
haley that is crystal clear
crystal clear
david thanks so much for taking your
time to cover the rally as a father of
two young ones i understand how
difficult this can be by the way we
tried cloth diapers but daycare required
disposable
well that's another that's another can
of worms for sure
i want to say thank you to some people
who have signed up via twitch soulless
harmony sir rock
joe dies at the end and micro kimmy
putting us at 39 for the day really
appreciate that also a bunch more people
signing up on my website let's say thank
you and welcome to linda sutton
kevin bartecho
link j
brandon manley
amanda bunch
jen h
and corey coddle
all signing up on my website putting us
at 46
which i appreciate all right let's take
a tour of the crazy
and see some of the things that have
been going on including i believe
outside the rally
uh hold on are we on oh we want latest
tweets here we go
hate preacher we're gonna skip oh here's
some new alex jones pablum it's here the
second atlantis
and you know how atlantis ended
and america was founded
by francis bacon and others
to be the new atlantis
and so that's where we are and the
decision has been made and you can see
the arguments are there especially the
public doesn't say no to this this is a
test to go ahead and wipe out
90 plus percent of the population
and quite frankly if the population
doesn't care it doesn't get engaged
doesn't get involved
the population does deserve to die the
children don't but definitely the adults
and the slobs and the decadent people
anybody know what he's talking about
uh that that that they think they're
winning in this corrupt system and think
this is all funny those people
deserve to die
i'm not going to kill them we shouldn't
kill them
but i'm simply explaining they're
projecting their own loathing of
themselves onto us and they want us to
die and i'm simply telling them don't
worry you're not going to have to wait
long you're going to be in a dystopia
and die too
so go ahead and pretend like you're part
of the power structure you're not but
then there's the real luciferians
okay so anyway completely disconnected
from reality
uh let's see what else is going on here
[Music]
we've got posts about this
don't care about hannity really
oh i guess bannon bannon found guilty
today appeared on tucker's show site
committee and we have to have a real
january 6 committee including to get to
the staffers now and see about the lies
and misrepresentations they put on
national television to the famed people
you're gonna i would tell the january
6th staff right now preserve your
documents because there's going to be a
real committee and this is going to be
backed by republican grassroots voters
and maggots say we want to get to the
bottom of this for the good of the
nation we have to know everything that
went on all the intelligence reports
exactly what went on what was ray's
involvement was fbi asset involvement
site committee all right so he has an
idea i guess of what he thinks is going
to happen
um david you should check out our dark
brandon subreddit it's pro biden me
marie and fantastic all right we'll
check it out david have you thought
about stand-up comedy your delivery is
great the diaper thing is an example of
one of your good premises hmm all right
no i have not thought about stand up
uh carrie lake is the person that
trump's supposedly endorsing at this
stupid rally
and they are with us
and frankly i think that's the coolest
story out there i mean think about it
think about this movement
it is such a great story but the filthy
fake news won't even cover it
the only media outlets there are right
wing
that's right
no they just want to attack us they want
to attack us every day every day they're
so worried about us they just attack us
and i want to tell them something how
boring guy
got 81 million votes
okay
all righty
yeah but
it's like even the crowd seems kind of
bored with this stuff
blake masters also spoke at the rally
and now as a candidate i'm getting a
taste of that firsthand the new york
times the washington post they lie about
me because they're terrified of me right
okay here's ben and asked about is he
ready to go to jail over this
bannon found guilty today of contempt of
congress by the way
how do you feel about going to jail are
you confident you would be safe there
for example
first off if i go to jail i go to jail i
will never back off a second look i
spent eight years as a naval officer
i've committed my life to this program
to this program to get this done i will
never get what done or back off i
support trump in the constitution and
i'm not backing off one inch if i go to
jail so be it
okay well he might i mean cool man
uh
it's all kind of weird but
and we got all the moms trust me we've
got the suburban moms are you out there
we've got the city moms and we got the
rural moms and they are all with us
each and every one of them
because when mama goes magga
it is game over
[Applause]
okay
let's see what else we've got
marjorie taylor green implies there's a
divine reason for rape pregnancy
oh this i have to say
do you think abortion should be banned
totally
i am
unapologetically i believe in life at
conception i do i think that and i'll
tell you why not answer it by saying yes
because i'm a mom i have three kids
and there's nothing that i could ever do
in my life even if i became president
even if i created world peace i there's
nothing i could do in my life that would
be greater than being a mom because i
love my kids that much and it's i
consider it a true blessing
so and i don't think anyone is a mistake
i do not i believe that every single
person
that god uh has a plan for them even if
they're unwanted even if they came out
of a horrible rape or something i just i
truly believe that let me look there's a
reason for them now
by that logic
if god works in mysterious ways and god
has a plan for everyone
couldn't god's plan be an abortion i
mean like is it
what i i want to be clear about what i'm
saying
if you're buying into that and you go
okay
god is a plan for everyone
abortion exists
in god's world
is it not possible god's plan is
abortion i mean like if you want to go
into that
and which god fair question i want to
separate this into two uh distinct
questions right there's the question of
marjorie taylor green's sanity and
there's the question of marjorie taylor
green's intelligence let's separate it
out so we can really disaggregate it in
the same area right there is the
political implementation of a ban versus
the personal feeling there should be
right do you personally feel abortion is
wrong and shouldn't be allowed yes
that's how i personally feel politically
do you think in the entire nation there
should be a nationwide ban on abortion
in every state at the federal level if i
had to vote on that yes i would vote on
that
vile vile vile woman really vile
really really vile
uh okay let me thank a few other people
so i don't fall behind thanks to by
staying
an anonymous gifter and dave schmidt for
the twitch prime subscriptions also want
to thank people signing up on my website
and they are numerous i want to say
thank you to dan
sloane
and
alistair marble
darren brown
lou silverman
and michelle jordan all new members on
my website and then also people gifting
memberships i won't name all of them
because there's a bunch but it's one two
three
four five
five more gifted memberships there
putting us at 59. i really appreciate
that thank you very much
i'm having an existential crisis my
super chat was missed i am not sure i am
really here apologies uh sandra i don't
know that i can easily go back
yeah it's not really working
okay i apologize i'm trying to get all
of them
i heard bannon's sentence was a minimum
of 30 days if that's the case it's way
too short would he even really break a
sweat from 30 days it doesn't seem the
punishment fits the crime i have not
read anything yet about the potential
sentence for bannon i don't know let me
let me investigate first
what time is that freak supposed to come
out trump's coming out in 15 minutes if
he's on time
that's what uh
that's what we're being told
welcome to certified urologist who is
new member number 60 today i appreciate
that
magga equals make attorneys get
attorneys yes i have mentioned that
before
sir since most likely trump won't get
charged with anything can anything be
done from a legal perspective to keep
him out of office
um
yeah i mean something similar to what
they tried to do to marjorie taylor
green but i don't think each state would
have to do it i believe
how do these people justify miscarriages
caused by pollution it would seem to me
that would be non-consensual
corporate-based abortion they just don't
think about that jack they just don't
think about it
um
couple other voicemails
hey david um
so
i was wondering
if you heard that uh
it just released that your uh
dehumidifier has actually given uh
testimony uh regarding the election no
no no i don't use a dehumidifier i use a
humidifier i want it more humid
i don't i don't own a dehumidifier
by marjorie taylor green's logic her god
wants people to sexually assault others
insanity it's all insane
it's all insane let's go back to some of
our clips okay um
this guy wants to go after fauci
and i promise you
we are going to investigate and
prosecute anthony fauci
what a big boy
uh let's see what else we've got
this is the guy who found hunter biden's
laptop
here was the introduction for
ted cruz at a turning point usa
conference check this out he has managed
to unify the country everyone agrees
he's doing a terrible job
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
wow
oh that i have to hear again
wow
wow
wow wow wow
hard to satirize that huh
that is maximum cringe maximum maximum
cringe
uh let's see what else we have here
look at this we looked at that
here's a little more from ted cruz
i talked to a student recently at one of
our woke college campuses who said she's
required in every class to introduce
herself
and to give her pronouns
[Applause]
well i'm ted cruz and my pronoun is kiss
my ass wow
a principle than defiant ted cruz
wow
i can see that you guys love
the rule of law and law enforcement and
we appreciate that
right
do you know who else loved the rule of
law and who loves the rule of law donald
trump
i need 11 000 votes give me a break
real lover of the law
channel idea social capital with david
pakman okay that's a that's a good idea
we are too gentle with the neo-fascists
in this county says alex mage i feel
that the only way to manage them is
ostracism
exclusion and silencing wow
very aggressive very very aggressive
let's see if we've got a couple other
clips here
looked at this one already
lauren bo bear
ultra magga
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i'm a proud member of the orange
mafia oh my god
that's that's real
d do people understand
that
like in most countries
if you go hey
here's a political movement check this
out
hey stand up
yeah they assume this is either a joke
or untreated mental illness
that's it nobody believes that this is
real
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i'm a proud member of the orange
mafia
completely sane person right i mean
obviously
um
they did an opening prayer that's
typical lord god restore our education
system
we pray for our education system our
school teachers and our students yeah we
pray against evil schemes that try to
indoctrinate our children like trump
university
and we ask you father to put a hedge of
protection over every one of our
children while at school
lord god we ask for the american church
to rise up
we pray that american turks wakes up how
is this real
how is this real life i mean really it's
it's disturbing let's make sure we're
not missing anything yet no not quite
yet
um let's see what else we have here
ron desantis attacked woke math let's
listen to that
we also see things like
i will have math books sent to my
department of education for review these
textbooks
and they will do things like woke math
and i'm thinking to myself they have
like black protractors and stuff like
that
two plus two equals four
it's not two plus two well let's have a
struggle session over that how do you
feel about it no no no there's a right
answer here
and it's not about injecting ideology
into concepts like math so what we did
at the department of education was we
sent the books back we said we don't
want all these other
concepts injected into our math and you
know what happened
partly because we're a big state and
they need the market but these textbook
companies had no other choice but to
take the woke out
he once saw a racist exponent and he
simply wasn't going to stand for it what
a delusional clown i mean really really
dangerous guy and he could he could be
the next president that's the really
scary thing
he could genuinely be the next president
super chats
it's aggressive but i i would argue in a
legal system that protects and at times
encourages their behavior what other
options do we have thank you alex
lady gaga has her little monsters trump
has his orange mafia
yeah
oh i'm sorry i'm realizing i missed some
people ringo starr sent five gifts on
twitch
also thanks to clarence thomas gina and
dave schmidt that is eight putting us at
68.
also want to say thank you to matt plogg
and cindy eckerd
who signed up on my website under new
members numbers 69 and 70.
let's do a couple more
voicemails
hi david this is stephanie me and my
fiance jose are big fans of the show and
we live in arkansas and i was just
wondering what your thoughts were on
our senator jason rapper wanting to make
travel bans for women and
if you think this actually could be an
effect and you know be a threat to us
women we were just curious on your
thoughts
travel ban for women
i am not finding anything about that
is it related to abortion like to
prevent women from traveling for an
abortion i don't even i don't even
i haven't read about that i'm gonna have
to look into that
geez
that's crazy though
thanks to robert for the 50 super chat
appreciate that also thanks to neglected
pizza crusts for the 750 i believe that
that's yen
dear god please protect our children
from the guns we've profited off of
yeah
that's uh that's depressing i'll tell
you that see what it sounds like in the
room
[Music]
oh people are caught this is
the music is remind people want to see
my favorite clip of all time
oh i'll play we looked at it yesterday
but but i'll play it again
honestly i could watch this thing a
million freaking times
this is a one of these
you know christian churches
where
they found a guy
and he was delivered and he was no
longer gay
except really he was but at least for
this day he wasn't
break every yoke
break him of yoke
he's delivering you this is if this
weren't real this would be
the most genius comedy in the history of
humanity
you need god to do
yeah he just told you it's done right
now what did you come here for what did
you come down here for tell me to get
delivered more get delivered
do you believe that the lord tonight has
set you free yes sir absolutely
turn around and tell those people
i'm not gay no more i am delivered there
is
i don't like men no more
i said i like women
women
i'm not gay
i would not date a man pretty big
declaration huh
i would not tear a purse i would not put
on makeup by the way why is it that at
these churches there's always guys in
suits walking around in the background
like there's just nobody can sit still
have you guys noticed that there's
always just people wandering around in
the background i will
i will
love
all women
listen to it
y'all praise god with him hold on wait a
minute
hold just one minute
now either you gonna believe this stuff
or you ought to stop preaching it
if you can't praise god with him you're
an unbeliever
that somebody believed god with him
[Music]
this is the best part
[Music]
after announcing he's no longer gay he
they just a bunch of dudes dance
together to prove how much he's been
quote cured this is so
crazy we preach reconciliation
there's like a frantic energy to this
that's bizarre
this woman's about to faint but she's so
shocked by how not gay the guy is that
she's about to pass out
[Music]
a lot of people having medical events on
the on the heels of this news
[Music]
[Applause]
this also by the way doesn't make the us
look super sane when people in overseas
see this stuff
hold on
hold on because i got a problem here i
got a problem i got to get out of here
because i got to get up early too and
put that long robe on right i got a
problem though
it still looks like he's alone oh
to prove how he's not gay
i need a man to come forward to go home
with him tonight and whether you know it
or not the devil ain't gonna leave him
alone right
[Music]
they will prove how not gay he is by
dancing now
there it is
[Music]
that's right
okay anyway so here's the guy
oh
i come to drink the tea and sympathy
[Music]
yes honey i am back you guys know me as
i am delivered but my name is andrew but
deliver it with the t i'm back
here in november of 2014 in the um in
the saint louis it was our holy
convocation that we have every year i
was new to the church of god of christ i
was new to church
at the time i was always been in church
my whole life but it has grown i was new
to it only going to church just to shout
i love this guy and to see who i was
going to sleep with
with pastor
but at that church
they delivered out of me they were
snatching that out of me but now i get
hard for women
i don't get hard for men
ain't nothing wrong with the flirtation
but i'm still delivered the morning that
i woke up
god told me to go to the store i went
got me a bow tie
anyway it's it's crazy that's maybe my
favorite clip ever ever ever ever
uh wow i mean that is really something
else something else mostly i feel bad
for the guy you know like someone who
convinced them to do this stuff it's
crazy
really crazy i know it's speculative but
any chance gavin newsom would pick katie
porter or another progressive as a
running mate let's wait and see who the
knob you know it's
we're not even at 2022 people are
talking about the hypothetical gavin
newsom running mate let's let's take a
chill on that you know let's wait a
little bit
imagine thinking you didn't pray hard
enough to build a hedge around your kids
to keep them from getting murdered at
school insane and sad very much so
well said nicholas well said
thanks to what do we have here
for the twitch prime subscription you
are number 71
also big thank you three new members on
my website they are dreama conrad
stephen poulos
and aubry levesque
putting us at 74. folks the goal is a
hundred
i think we can knock this thing out of
the park we we have 11 000 people
watching not not i need 11 000 votes
give me a break we have 11 000 people
watching right now if just one percent
of you
go to my website joinpakman.com and grab
a membership you can use the coupon code
obama
you can also use the coupon code indict
that's the one that's over my head all
of these coupon codes are valid
this is actually our primary source of
funding i would love for you to do that
i think we can get a hundred completely
blown out of the park here that's my
that's my speculation
um let's do a couple more voicemails
hi david this is nico from southern
health
california um
i've asked you about
your believability about trump getting
convicted
however
um
what
is the step forward for
um
america
as
a country
with
half of
well give or take half of america
living in la la land and then
um
some of america who is like centrist
and i'm not totally sure where that was
going nico let me let me think on that
hey david uh
watching the show noticing tonight just
a little bit of hate i cannot
begin to articulate how much i enjoy
show
um
i watch it all the time maybe to an
unhealthy degree probably watching old
shows like from 2 2012.
listen
keep doing your thing you're fantastic
we live by you we want you you're the
best thank you that's a beautiful
message
appreciate that and on the heels of that
graveborn has just gifted
50
subscriptions on youtube you can now
gift subscriptions on youtube that is an
incredible thing graveborn gifted 100
yesterday and gifting 50 more
we're at 124. folks let's go for 150
let's do it i'm not afraid
the hague says david i'm from the
netherlands and i feel sad for the usa
over here dutch media is changing tune
fast abortion guns etc sadly message is
becoming that we are looking at a
country
going back to the middle ages yeah
it's uh
it's sad
you are
a hundred percent correct
that is the way it feels
david bill from north carolina again
hey man you got to add add to your list
of pro essentials and on those
yesterday is such a hard word for me to
say yep thanks man
absolutely
also i [ __ ] wanted to squeeze in one
more message just so you how no you know
how it [ __ ] feels to be forced to
deal with language that is [ __ ]
inappropriate near people who might
[ __ ] matter more oh my god whitney is
shot out of a cannon
in the scheme of things and how your
[ __ ] life operates when it's like
might you guys think the italian women
and the jewish men think that maybe
you're like spanish and that means you
think you better than everybody else
meanwhile if you go back home maybe your
[ __ ]
girlfriends or
husbands or whatever
might be excluded and maybe possibly die
and you're getting accused over there of
being a [ __ ] nazi whoa i don't know
what that's about i i
i'm gonna get away from that okay let's
let's instead listen to another pedantic
question from juan
hey david tuan
i need for you to convince me or explain
to me okay
how it makes any sense
to
take out
money out of your house
to take money out what are you talking
about equity or like walking out of your
house with cash and uh
be better off
in my case
my house is paid off
i only pay 53 a month
for my hoa which i hate okay i hate a
choice but anyway that's not the point
well and i assume you pay utilities and
property taxes and uh all right but
let's see where this is going
a friend of mine tells me that i should
take up money
take out a ball on the house
live life
wait what loan you said the house is
paid off what does that even he just
said the house is paid off but a friend
says you should take out money to cover
the loan what loan you said it's paid
off
and
do a maneuver
to um
basically offset the interest
to some type of investment blah blah
blah
that doesn't make any sense why because
right now i pay 53 if i do all of that
i'm still gonna end up paying
what
two three four hundred dollars
and i'm also gonna be paying interest
oh okay uh so i get let's assume let's
assume that i know what what he's
talking about so it sounds like what
he's saying is i have no mortgage a
friend of mine was like hey get a
mortgage
and then
invest the money you take out
and it's basically arbitrage so yeah i
mean this can work but you want interest
rates to be really low there is risk
the the to tip the the um what's the
right word here the the sort of like
dream example would be if you can get
you got a paid off house 500k okay
you can usually get 80 out of it so you
go and you find someone to give you a
hundred thousand dollar loan
um at two point five percent and then
you take the 400k you throw it in a
cheap index fund which over a long
period of time should return about seven
percent so you're making seven percent
your mortgage is 2.5 you make the
difference it's called arbitrage now of
course it's all much more complicated
than that uh there is a mortgage
interest deduction which you have to
figure in to calculate uh to calculate
that the money you invest in the index
fund could go down on and on and on so
you know you could i mean like you can
do that but it's risky
and
most people
shouldn't do it and i mean i don't know
dude juan i don't know it sounds like
with the numbers you're talking about 53
200
i wouldn't do that it just sounds like
it just sounds like it's not the right
level of risk for you okay
people are saying ten thousand dollar
state tax limit yeah i understand but
not everybody hits that
so in theory there's a mortgage interest
deduction you have to figure out whether
you yeah let's move on guys this this is
good this is getting bad thanks to mr
vister for the twitch prime subscription
you're number 125.
and a bunch of people signing up on my
website richard elliott is a new member
chad corrado
is a new member jack lightholder new
member raymond christensen
david johnson new member
um john phitopolis is a new member and
michael lee that's seven
putting us at 132
and we have
many more many more super chats coming
in
america's problems don't end with trump
going to prison
we have an absurd form of intolerant
christianity and a demented
understanding of our responsibility to
each other well said but also very sad
matt says take my money i support you
thank you for what you do please call
what we are seeing what it is fascism
not offended
okay
there you go
finance
wars
wow
the stream's getting pretty bonkers
today not gonna lie
hey david watching the stream as always
i
have a special request tonight i had a
surgical injury and so i'm at home
watching your stream and i must ask if
you ever followed up with dave figaro
on the uh
the fossil fuel
costs of his tattoos
what what is that
if you ever followed up with dave
figueroa
dave figaro does anybody know what
they're talking about dave figaro
on the uh
the fossil fuel
um cost of his tattoos
and
um secondly when you went to yuma why in
the world were even yuma i understand
that uh you hated the place but uh just
like this while you were there when you
had your california trip oh yeah i can
explain all right
hope the kids doing well
thanks beautiful
so uh let's see if i can hold on let me
see if i can get this set up here
the reason i was in yuma and it is
certainly an unusual place for me to be
is last uh december i spent a bunch of
time in tucson
which was great
and then went to san diego and then up
to la
and the natural halfway point for lunch
what what i determined was okay we're
not gonna stop for lunch here because
this is too soon this is only like 50
minutes out so that doesn't make any
sense once you get out to this part
all these places gila bend
fiba
there's literally nothing here there's
nothing to do like even if we wanted to
stop here check out the street view on
this insanity like i'm stopping for
lunch here guys
so what i determined was that the best
option
was to stop for lunch in yuma very very
close to the border
with california and it was horrible i
mean it was really truly a horrible
place
um i'll kind of show you what it looks
like
yeah
but that's where we stopped for lunch
that was it uh
we went to a place i think it was quite
literally called like asian restaurant i
think that was the name of it and then
on really interesting part of the drive
though
i want to say it's right around here
you get oh no no no here yeah this is
like a very interesting hilly area i i
enjoyed the drive here
yeah it was cool it was different anyway
that that was the deal with that so
that's why i found myself in yuma
arizona
uh kind of unremarkable in in most ways
i think i would say
um let's see what else we've got
if i win the mega millions tonight i'll
buy mangoes for everybody yeah i heard
the mega millions is up to some crazy
amount
yeah okay very good
let's listen to a couple others here
david is chuck calling from englewood
los angeles california
eat our nurse libtard
feminist
uh
jewish wife
the whole shebang i'm about as
on the left as they get
and i thought this would be a pretty
safe is having a jewish wife kind of
does that give you left credentials i've
never heard that
here for me until i heard that
there were some proud boys over in santa
monica recently
kind of shattered my little belief that
california is going to be this bastion
of
sense and normalcy but
obviously that is not going to be the
case
it's my official call to arms for
anyone else like-minded who's
looking to
defend
uh libtard stand by stand up and stand
by
uh because you're not safe
all right so a cautionary tale there
very very important cautionary tale
heart
hard to go wrong with that
hey david this is andrew fox from
southern california big fan of the show
watching the stream right now and
something i wanted to call in about
is
the sort of difference take between you
and kyle kalinski
shut up siri are you are you serious
this is crazy
anyway
you and kyle kalinski have radically
different takes this is [ __ ]
ridiculous scary shut up
uh-huh
listen i don't know anything about kyle
kolinsky
[Laughter]
i don't watch any shows uh like mine so
i don't i just don't know
it's more than 100 degrees in arizona
tonight all those people are insane for
many reasons one of them being leaving
the house in this crazy weather it is uh
it's hot everywhere right now yeah
hala
is how you say it great mexican food
there if you look alright so maybe
that's where i should have stopped
maybe that was the spot
i want to say thank you to janiece
tsuchi
for the new membership ralph quatrucci
for the new membership
and kevin gill just signed up on my
website joinpackman.com
very much appreciate that also thank you
to tron
truonyat
panda 317 and hex parament
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 138. yeah one of those
names did remind me
of one of trump's mispronunciations
exactly
good evening david sir with the super
majority conservative court are facing a
situation that no matter how progressive
the president or legislative branch the
cur court just overturns everything
oh boy joe
we love you i don't know what you're
talking about my friend
trump's outtakes last night showed some
tasty anger issues by the way i didn't
know you wear glasses too i get mine
from zeni optical hope you and your
family are doing well love the show yeah
i wear contacts or glasses i'm like a
minus 3.75 with uh with pretty powerful
astigmatism the kids tell me
david if there was one thing you would
do to heal the divide between democrats
and republicans what would you do if
perception is the truth and others have
different perspectives what is truth
well that's getting a little bit
metaphysical for my take but i do think
i mean it's cliched to say this
but as humans we really do agree about
most things
and
we need to simultaneously not minimize
the horribly destructive views of these
right-wing nuts but recognize that on so
many massively important issues
we are basically on the same page about
what counts as human decency etc and
also on a bunch of different issues
we're not and we shouldn't minimize that
we shouldn't minimize that
hi david this is mike
from oregon just want to call to say
i've been watching you since uh
back when you used to only get like a
thousand views per video
and uh it's been a
uh pretty cool seeing you um get as big
as you have and it's cool watching you
uh [ __ ] all over conservatives and stuff
all the time oof
and uh yeah just wanted to say keep at
it man thank you i appreciate that
i like that
oh hi david this is uh
david from alabama
and i know you're well past tired of
talking about that
that so-called movie 2000 mules but i
thought i'd let you know about there was
another one i saw a trailer for a while
back
about another unhinged trump conspiracy
theory that the
election was stolen and all that it's
called
rigged
so
i thought you might take a look into
that and see what you get
to uh
come up with
and uh yeah
maybe i mean i'm a little sick of those
films they're really
pretty horrifying
hey david just wondering if you wanted
to do a quick commentary on that weird
tick that trump did
while he was trying to see the word vote
during his
the most recent gen 6 outtake
video it's really interesting and i
think
it shows a lot about sort of the
psychology and self-editing
trump had a tick on vote let's see
trump outtakes i didn't notice that
might not have been watching closely
enough let's see
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
and to those who broke the law
you will pay
you do not represent our movement you do
not represent our country
and if you broke the law
you can't say that
i'm not you i already said you will pay
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defied the seat of destiny it's
defiled right see i can't see it very
well okay i'll i'll do this i'm gonna do
this let's go but this election is now
over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the elections are but
i just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
don't go to the paragraph before
okay
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
yesterday's a hard word for me
good take the word yesterday because it
doesn't work with
the heinous attack
on our country say on our country so
where is this thing say that
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
i don't know that that's a glitch i just
think he didn't like it i don't know
that seems a little different it is
funny it's obviously it's funny but uh i
don't really know what to make
of that it's it's bizarre it's all
strange it's all very strange i'm not
going to deny that that's for sure
hey this is a chat from phoenix arizona
watching your stream of trump
in arizona
you were talking about having to
eat dinner and or lunch and you mind
yeah i agree you must kind of trash um
i don't know if you're going to hear
this voicemail during the stream i hope
you do
but i want to know if you've ever been
to phoenix arizona i live in phoenix
actually i live in chandler arizona it's
a suburb of phoenix
but um
i honestly really love living in phoenix
but it's beautiful weather yeah it gets
hot yeah i've i've been to phoenix very
briefly very i don't really i don't
really don't know much about it
hey david thanks for answering the
question about yuma as i uh stated i am
recovering from a surgery injury so i am
drugged and not all here all right well
that's okay all right let's let's
hi david this is tyra i'm calling from
arkansas i was just wondering if
you had seen about arkansas
and the
plan b pill
being up for debate in this state
i saw yesterday that
the congress
the congress well
that congress
hmm
did they just hang up
the voicemail's still going
see if i skip ahead
no they just they just hung up
alex says dave you're right i've spent
most of my life traveling my biggest
takeaway is we all want the same things
any differences are minor compared to
our similarities yes doesn't mean that
the differences don't hugely impact
people's lives to be clear
david what would a pacman audio board
audio clipboard include i'm thinking
unhinged shot out of a canon scary stuff
agit trash took a wish agit trash took
off yes someone should make a sound
board for me
that'd be good we need to return to
feudalism this democracy stuff is
driving people nuts
aguante river
okay
i don't really follow
argentinian
soccer i just followed the men's
national team and we are getting ready
for a major major world cup trump i
don't want to say the election's over us
we know love the show david getting my
bingo card ready everyone is on wacky
pills tonight very much so
wacky wacky wacky pills
let's see what else we've
got david sir
this is uh tom from seattle
i can't help but notice but most
leftists and progressives watch and
learn more right-wing talking points
than our own whereas a reactionary
person would probably shield themselves
from your quote woke streams we
highlight theirs and it's just weird
uh we can agree that the right is a
total clown show but
how are we going to turn that into
leftist action
well we address that significantly
on the show i think it's fair
um
yeah okay let's let's leave it at that
hey this is kind of interesting
uh i had an interesting call with a
caller this is not yet live about
puberty blockers
check this out see if you find this
interesting let's go next to
where do we want to go there's so many
people who want to be on let's go to
saigon mike saigon mike you're next
mike
you're unmuted but i'm wondering if you
have the wrong a little bit ago and he
said when he brought up um
his liking for desantis and you kind of
brought up he maybe doesn't really know
what he's talking about but do you think
the possibility maybe
that he sees more in line even though he
is a progressive
he sees more in line with some of the
stuff that um
desantis is doing and isn't really happy
with uh something like uh dinner kind of
presents we're doing like with biden
this gets pretty cringy i'm just warning
you guys
uh no that sounds weird to me i mean if
if rogan
is more progressive
he couldn't possibly like what desantis
is doing if he knows what desantis is
doing
but i i uh but all i'm saying is that
the way that the
he he can still be progressive but not
like the that things that the democratic
party is going too far and that the
santas would be the campus and people
like the scientists might isn't as far
right as they're actually saying they're
as extreme
well i mean you're saying is it possible
that something rogan hasn't said is
what's in his head and it's like i guess
so but we have no reason to think that
that's what rogan thinks it's sort of
like mind reading you know
no no like i guess an
example
for me is that the whole the way that
the progressive movement has been going
with uh trying to
push like uh puberty blockers on
children and the trans athletes which is
like i know a subject that
uh joe rogan opposes what the way that's
going and that someone may be on the
right
that it would be more open to his view
of like how the just wait that that
should be
played
i'm not aware of
the movement among progressives to push
puberty blockers on kids can you tell me
more about that
uh
wasn't the health secretary literally
out there saying that
the kids should be able to transition
and use puberty blockers if they feel
like they're in the wrong body
oh uh okay because first you said that
there were there was a movement pushing
puberty blockers on kids it sounds like
what you're saying is
one biden administration official said
that for the tiny percentage of people
in that situation and the subsection
within that that wants to pursue such
drugs that it should be possible is that
what you what you actually meant
um i mean
the first thing you said was that
progressives are pushing puberty
blockers on kids but then your example
wasn't that was it
i mean
okay pushing the idea of using
puberty blockers on kids if you want to
be more
straightforward about it well when you
say that it sounds like you're saying
that there's a movement to just convince
children to take puberty blockers but
there isn't any movement like that is
there
um
it seems there's no way i would i would
say so okay so who is going around
saying hey what we want is we want more
kids to take puberty blockers who's
saying that
uh
the fighting administration for kids who
want to take puberty blockers
oh but so what you're saying is the
biden administration
has a position that
in certain situations for the tiny
percentage of kids who identify as being
in the wrong body for lack of a better
term
and for whom
medical professionals believe it would
be appropriate to make that decision
it should be a decision they are allowed
to make right because that's very
different than they are pushing puberty
blockers on kids
uh i would say
anyone like i guess the well let me give
you an example to make it really clear
oh what i guess let me let me let me let
me clarify i guess from my spot for you
give your example sorry
this gets even worse
just so you can get your comeback um so
i guess from joe rogan's perspective is
that the kid like a kid that age let's
just say
five six younger than that
like we they can't they can't enter into
contracts they can't do other stuff
because they don't have the mental
capacity to actually understand yep if
there it maybe would be in the wrong
body or not in the wrong body or
anything like that and i'm not talking
about adults or anything i'm talking
about kids got it that it would be it
and the harmful effects they could have
on tv bonkers with them and their mind
not being able to fully understand
what's going on would you apply that
same logic to children getting vaccines
where the kids can't actually consent
themselves the parents are doing it for
them and they don't understand the full
impact of those and once you do it you
can't undo the fact that you've gotten a
vaccine would you apply the same
standard to the vaccines i'm curious
uh
vaccines um
it's very
interest um
no i guess i i wouldn't but i guess i
would i guess i guess i guess i'm going
back to like
do
kids actually understand i think i can
understand more of a vaccine if they're
if the parent talks about them talks
about it to them so it sounds like
you're saying it's actually not about
whether the kids can or can't sign
contracts or are of legal age it's
whether they can understand a concept
based on what their parents tell them
that's the standard you're now laying
out
no i'm not i'm not saying there's a
standard saying that
forcing
oh my standard is right i i don't think
i i i i don't think kids
understand exactly what they're doing
with the the puberty blockers and more
of the long-term effects that could have
on them versus like a vaccine i guess
which is
which is different i mean look i'm sure
but like
in a few weeks my daughter will be due
for vaccines she can't understand them
and no matter how i explain it to her
she's not gonna understand them by your
standard about understanding i shouldn't
be allowed to get her vaccinated right
uh i'm not saying i'm not saying i don't
think she'd be allowed to get her
vaccinated right what i'm asking you is
you said the standard that makes
vaccines different than puberty blockers
is
the kids better understand vaccines
rather than their understanding of
puberty blockers i just explained my
daughter doesn't understand vaccines at
all should by your standard
she should not i should not be able to
get her vaccinated in a couple weeks
based on your standard
i didn't say that was a standard of mine
i was saying i literally asked you
what's your standard and you said that's
your standard my standard is they can't
understand it
not on vaccines i guess i say i was
saying my understanding would be
able to explain vaccines versus puberty
blockers and the whole and all those
side effects moving forward
transitioning and everything like that i
mean okay i
i'm but again i'm basically i'm what was
my basic question is
my base my basic going back to the joe
rogan part was yeah more under uh and i
i guess i don't know why i guess my
pushing
is uh i'm not saying they're just like
going up and giving up kids puberty
blockers but more of the emphasis on
transitioning younger kids when it when
the long term
this is even worse than my memory of it
they probably won't be able to
understand what's actually going on with
their body got it so let's so let's say
let's now drill down to what we are
talking about so
you're not saying
that they are let's go just follow me
step by step you're not saying anyone is
forcing puberty blockers physically into
children right you're not making the
claim anybody's doing that no that came
across that way that's not true no no
i'm not saying it i'm just i'm let me
clear so you're not saying anyone is
forcibly being given puberty blockers
good second
is there any campaign to go out and say
hey kids
consider puberty blockers it's cool like
is there a pr campaign or you're saying
there isn't that either
um i wouldn't say there's a pr campaign
to like say it's cool but i think
there's a
campaign slash strategy a movement of
like putting more of a
uh
spotlight on them
for younger for younger kids basically
in
uh
with
doctors schools within the
administration everything so you're
saying that there are schools where they
do presentations and they go hey kids if
you're not feeling good about your body
how about puberty blockers that's
happening somewhere
i wouldn't say that they would say pure
blockers in there if i'd say within
schools they're trying they're it's
implicit guys
more or less i guess going into like uh
gender identity
and everything in every sexuality and
everything like that which would would
bring the conversation moving towards
that do you have any evidence that in
schools where they talk about the fact
that trans people exist they're pushing
puberty blockers is there a single
example of such a school
um i mean wait do like the example where
they're mentioning puberty blockers in
like the like the teachers said the word
puberty brock blockers yeah where
they're saying not when when issues of
gender are taught in schools
where puberty blockers are being talked
about by teachers and presented as
something to pursue or something you
said remember at the beginning of the
call you said pushing the word was
pushing i'm looking for someone so i'm
not saying again i like i said i don't
think that they're like the teachers
themselves are saying uh are pushing
puberty so it's not the teachers either
like they're going the same puberty
blockers and saying that the comment
like the thought process and the the
transition to the end result with
transitioning if you read rockers is in
like um
you may not like pushing the whole idea
again i'm not i if adult wants to make a
decision i'm not against anything at all
i'm saying kids specifically pushing
ideas
but you you started the call by saying
that something is being pushed and we've
gone piece by piece and you're
acknowledging you can't actually
identify anyone pushing it
i mean everyone i ask you is this person
pushing it is that person pushing it you
go well no
what is your definition of pushing it
promoting encouraging
yeah i mean the body administration is
encouraging kids
okay now we're starting now we start
over with just a different word no but
no steve now we're back to the beginning
that was your first claim which already
fell apart all right steve thank you for
the call i'm gonna let you go okay so
anyway that was that that's uh that's
the type of stuff for better or worse
that's going on we do do you guys think
i could have done another 10 minutes
simply repeating the entire conversation
with the word encouraging instead of
pushing
i i feel like we could have started over
at the beginning and i could have just
done it again just every time i said
pushing encouraging and done the exact
same conversation with the exact same
results
30 minutes more some people think yeah
man that's uh wow wow it was it was
something else it was exhausting to even
do it let's listen to what's happening
in the room here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody know what's going on
[Music]
well let's see what's going on here this
is like on a sad shoulder
isn't that beautiful it's just so fun
like this is what it's about right
this is what it's all about is doing
this
[Music]
oh thank you
what's his name again
adam collins
your mom says hi adam clark you're
watching us right now
your mom says hi
adam clark uh but now would be a great
time we want to encourage everybody
right now to uh to go to our website
dot rsbnetwork.com that's rsb
network dot com and uh you know we're
we've got great patrons like mike
lindell but we've also got great pages
like yourself watching us right now yeah
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines it's getting pretty
crazy at this rally i'm not going to lie
it's getting very very crazy i want to
say thank you to andrew avr drums for
gifting to actually three subscriptions
on my website also thanks to suzanne
cooper smith
for signing up that puts us at 142 and
over on twitch queen of wildfire has
just grabbed the twitch prime
subscription we have a goal folks of 150
new website members and twitch
subscribers today
we are okay 150 minus 143. zero minus
three is zero but you need a one boom
that's seven
okay
five
but we brought it down to four with the
carry so it's 4 minus 4 is 0
and then 1 minus 1 is 0.
we are 7 away from 150 if my math checks
out
is that right that doesn't look right
damn
now i guess that's right that's probably
right i appreciate that thank you
everybody keep those memberships coming
do you normally interview farm animals
or was that special that was special
similar to that logic logical debate i
think you might appreciate pro-life
protesters confronted with veganism oh
boy
oh boy we'll see about that
uh thanks to action jeff for the twitch
prime subscription that is number 144.
um let's see what else we have here
um oh we got a ton
of uh voicemails
hey david this is ralph quatrucci i just
want to thank you for the proper
pronunciation of my name i've been
watching your show for years pleasure i
know you stole sam cedar set but i still
watch you anyway i stole his glasses
keep going
thank you yeah when when i saw quatrucci
i was like that's i can't think of any
other way
that that would uh
that that would be pronounced okay let's
listen
hey david uh just calling to see now
that you have your own bundle of joy uh
what your
stroller model is i know that my wife
and i found that the stroller we used
was the upper baby vista because it was
the one that had the largest under
seat storage that's exactly what i have
yep the upper baby vista i think it's
it's in you should see what they charge
for this crap
and so we never had to take our
car seat off of the stroller to put it
into a shopping cart or something like
that we would just go to the grocery
store fill the bottom of the stroller
walk up and pay for all of the things
there anything we could do to
make sure that our newborn stayed asleep
hope you're having a great time in this
you know very early window and yep no
that's uh that's the thing it's uh
it's quite a scene that's for damn sure
let's see if i have anything else that's
interesting here
hey dave this is andrew from uh alabama
uh look uh
you know we gotta wash our hands for
covet but the sink water is just not
enough
there's not enough water coming off the
sink
there's drain flies everywhere
can't flush the toilet he's told it's on
flush
i don't get
but 2022 what's going on
okay all right
kind of an unusual
voicemail
um
let's see if i have anything else here
for you
david sir
you heard my feelings man
you think i am a pedantic caller
unbelievable man
i know i was a troll
but i'm trying to change man yeah
pedantics not bad just juan sometimes
asks some
sort of pedantic questions david have
you ever heard of the youtube channel
let's talk elections never
if you have to guess what percentage of
americans are hardcore trumpist trump
supporting condoners against trump but
with their head in the sand and those
who understand the danger of this stuff
uh
hardcore trumpists
the problem with percent of america is
like only half the country votes
so are we saying what percentage of the
voters or what percentage of america i'd
have to think about that and do like a
pie chart
not sure totally offhand
oh yeah i did and when you had mentioned
that mr peterson had been really
hands-on with you i could notice an
entire demeanor in your in your facial
change
it's pretty clear david you were the one
that enjoyed it
but i think in reality what happened was
that you were the one that was rubbing
up on mr jesse lee so i think it's it's
kind of obvious i think many people can
see you're just projecting your
homosexual urges it's a very thick thing
to do
okay i mean
if i was gay i would just tell you
what's the big deal who even cares
uh all right let's see
hey david i'm really excited about your
new finance channel whenever it launches
here's another idea how about
finance semicolon unpacked
uh or finance dash unpacks just a slight
syntactical modification there but
basically that's the idea
i think it's pretty good and it doesn't
really include an inside joke which
could uh be off-putting to people who
don't follow kind of the main channel so
kind of uh takes into consideration all
audiences i mean what do you think
well it's certainly an idea
david pakman
you are a loser
huh
that sounded a lot like alex jones
uh
interesting the area code actually
was that really alex jones
david pac-man
you are a loser
that actually might be alex jones
huh
let's just listen to it once more
david pac-man
you are a loser
wow
if it's not alex jones it's a pretty
damn good impression
keep up the good work david but you
can't argue with stupid that is
absolutely true
absolutely true
pac-man's a loser
dogfish birds and blueberry babe as well
as espyrans
and ozzy
have all signed up via twitch prime i
want to say thank you to jim
baxter as well as
pamela baez
who are new members 149 and 150 today
also four additional memberships gifted
on my website putting us at
154 very much appreciate that that is a
very powerful declaration
bannon's punishment for destabilizing
western democracies worldwide backed by
russia is
two years at the max in jail a hundred
thousand dollar fine sigh i'm ashamed
sir i know
i know
this rally venue paired with the music
they were playing was the most ghastly
that i've ever witnessed seriously
creepy as hell also what channel is this
3abc5 it's a bizarre channel
[Music]
isn't this weird
[Music]
completely dystopian circumstances here
into the system
and we bring it to election day voting
you show idea if we do all of that and
we still keep these machines
then we still can't have fair and honest
elections we have to get rid of the
machines
let's talk about your daily life or
we'll let you go you're on the campaign
trail every single day if you follow her
on social media we got to get rid of
those machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines the
schedule is like you do not sit back
you've got double-digit leads over your
opponents despite what the mainstream
media wants to convince you at home that
it's tight neck and neck this race is
not tight neck and neck but let's talk
about your daily schedule and you do not
take that for granted you are talking to
the people every day you're in people's
homes you're in churches you're in front
of businesses you're at the border
you're making you're working for imagine
having this woman in your house
and i want the people of arizona to know
that's how hard i will work as your
governor
i'm in this because i'm worried about
the direction our state's going in our
country it's not easy to get into
politics it's a lot of work but we need
someone who's going to get in there and
do the right thing we do four five six
events a day unbelievable we collapse
into bed at night and we get up and do
it again
but it's important it's important
because if we don't get it right carrie
lake truly is a monster absolutely it is
it is completely and utterly insane
uh complete and total monster thanks to
braided dragon for the twitch prime
subscription coming with the message you
be you
learning so much from you thank you for
staying true six months of being able to
support the channel listening much
longer thank you braided dragon i very
much appreciate that thank you thank you
uh do i have any other voicemails we're
down at the end on voicemails let's see
if i got anything else here
uh
david sir snap here
uh just listening to your show from
today uh friday
and i listened to you talk to the caller
about the joe rogan and puberty blockers
thing
and i gotta say first of all i respect
the fact that you gave the guy heir i
mean you understand that this is the
type of person that we're dealing with
on a daily basis
people who think that they know and that
they think that they're informed on
these things and then whenever you
finally start talking to them you
realize that they're just trying to spew
off whatever they heard on some other
network yep and they don't actually have
any idea what it is they're talking
about and their opinions make absolutely
zero sense
and
i i appreciate the fact that you that
you gave it here and you showed that
that was what was going on
and it just it was a it was a real
reality check you know to
the people who either don't understand
that they're that way
or the people who don't understand how
to approach somebody well good i'm glad
that
i'm glad that it was useful that's
important that's what we're trying to do
hi david renee from michigan so i'm
watching your friday show
and the first of all the one guy that
called in about the puberty blockers for
kids he was about driving me nuts like
you were really patient with him but
that phone call lasted way too long
well listen i was trying to
let it go to its logical conclusion and
hear how
deranged it was all going to be you know
that's basically that's basically the
point you know so and sometimes it takes
a little while
so um
i was reading uh jesus catherine's
um tarot cards
so on the one that's supposed to be him
or herself
um she got a page of cups
so page of cups on your tarot cards must
be pretty damn dangerous
that sounds uh
that sounds pretty bad
see what else we got here
i mean look at you for instance you even
said yourself you're an insensitive
person and you feel desensitized
and you agree with therapy and also
killing babies
so it's like and it's not just an
abortion like that's not an abortion
when you can actually see like a body
and it's obviously like the makings of a
human being it's not like it's going to
turn into a monkey at that point well
whitney is anti-choice now i didn't even
know that
i had no idea whitney was so so strongly
against
abortion hey
david hackman
i was watching louder with crowder and
uh they made an observation
alexandria ocasio-cortez
um her eyes are often bugged out boring
don't care don't care about crowder
don't care about what troy york has to
say boring boring do not care do not
care i mean i don't i don't know how
many times i have to explain it but
these people are so boring i want to say
thank you to dr mira love petrovic
who is new member number 159 coming in
strongly via twitch
via twitch
devin says sir cats is the most american
musical as it turns out thank you
show name mattresses of finance that's
an interesting idea
uh let's see what's happening here
[Music]
really a raucous atmosphere huh
great job thank you no it's great i mean
what they do think about this for a
second and while we have a couple of
minutes they recreate the biggest rock
show in the country
every single week and i'll challenge you
this i don't care what band you are you
cannot continually sell out arenas time
and time again for years for years
he's been doing this for a year and it's
not like president trump just had the
latest single out he you know he hasn't
been in office in two years
yeah he's up doing this right here you
know uh but he's still packing the house
and that just shows
how big
of a heart people have for him they like
him
yeah
and
i i think everyone's getting excited i'm
starting to get excited feeling like
he's about to come out
yeah we're glad you're joining us and
remember uh make sure you subscribe i
mean he's only make sure you subscribe
it's a suspicious subscription
he's only an hour late
so
yeah i guess he's like
probably coming out soon or something uh
i don't know
hey david this is michael j garcia
calling from beautiful san diego
california and i just want you guys to
all practice saying it with me now
cree hottest
okay
it's the radical right theocracy
fascists
pre-hottest
you know i think you're getting where
i'm going here right
taliban comparison
to the radical muslim jihadist
and now we have the american
radical fascist
pre-hottest okay i think we get it
hey david uh
just watching the
rally with you here they're talking
about the crowd size i want to mention
when they talk about
the sold out
uh crowd
uh most of these stadiums
like i'm pretty sure like this one has a
upper bowl that is i think every single
time completely
blocked out because not only that the
using the term sold out when the tickets
are free
like is that even accurate
sold out when you're giving away the
tickets i just don't know about that
that's that's a that's a question but
who knows
hey david i just was uh watching uh your
footage of uh um
trump rallies he just thought it was
hilarious how close are those reporters
to that camera because at different
times you can almost see their feet in
the camera with in the in the in the
same shot
uh what and i appreciate all your
commentary on uh all the news and
everything that's going on and with
everything that's going on in the world
with like uh russia and everything i
still want to say to you
sam heater set looks better on your
stage
have a good day wow that's a pretty
pretty big shot across the bow i must
say
hi david this is pete calling from
alabama stan big fan of the show am i
the only person that thinks that the
female host of rsbn
is the
actress from saving silverman
have a good night
um yeah you know this i'm pretty sure
that this is christina bob
and that she was like
trump's lawyer at one point or some
there's something about her she is a
lawyer
i don't remember what the deal was but
there's some kind of weird backstory
with her
i don't i don't remember the specifics
of it but it's pretty crazy
hey david ty from north carolina do you
think that trump's so late because he
really wants to talk about things that
went on at the january 6th hearing but
he's struggling with the word yesterday
when trying to reference the event
that's exactly right trump's working on
how to say yesterday behind the scenes
uh all right let me take a five since
this has been going so long we'll listen
to the sweet sounds of right side
broadcasting and then i'll be right back
to myself there's no way i'm going to
see in my lifetime at a male that's 52
years old i'm never going to see seven
dollar gas i didn't think that'd be a
reality but guess what folks in
california it's actually much higher
than that
yeah i mean he was right and he was
right about everything do you think
we're going to hear about hunter biden
tonight
um that would be fun everybody loves it
when he's the laptop from hell
yeah and the iphone that was hacked and
we got all these images of hunter biden
it's all stuff it's all stuff that we
should be talking about and we and
president trump warned us about the
corruption the biden crime family having
all these charisma and all these back
door dealings with china and the ukraine
hello ukraine who's in the news ukraine
ukraine yeah i think so so much going on
so you've got
literally about
67 seconds oh here we go here we go
let's step aside and see if this is it
live from prescott valley arizona let's
stand by
[Applause]
well christina i don't know
i feel like we struck out on that one
what happened
no no no it's coming
it's coming you think yeah but can they
cut the song midstream they're showing a
video on the screen upside i don't know
this is a tribute video oh it's oh
yeah let's stand by i'm not sure if we
got a shot of that or not we won't but
they are playing a tribute
video
um
of that a beautiful tribute video
and um can the viewers see the pictures
on the screen i'm not sure if they have
it on their screen right now okay i
don't think they do videos going through
family photos of the trump family with
ivana when uh the kids were younger
obviously they're grown
it's going through several several
generations or several decades i should
say
okay we do have a cut cam that is
showing that right now uh it's a
beautiful tribute and of course you're
seeing the early days of president trump
married he's got don jr you've got uh
eric trump uh you know it and this is
what we beautiful family photos this is
i guess what we expected this opening to
be yeah
yeah
god restaurant very sweet tribute
[Music]
beautiful moment here
in prescott valley
arizona
for ivana trump
stand by
as the music phase out what a beautiful
moment that was
let's see if perhaps
uh we get the call those famous words
[Music]
okay so they played another hype song
okay
okay
i'm gonna play producer here for a
second
he comes out after the song oh yeah
because you can't walk out after a a a
tribute a video right the moment just
was not right right but you can after
this very good analysis yeah i think you
can
spoken like a true professional in the
business
brian glenn
many many many decades of experience
maybe when i'm done with all of this
i'll sit back and like produce a rallies
i don't know what i'm gonna do yeah i
should uh but we think everybody watches
right now because we can honestly say
we're minutes away now and which which
puts us a little bit two and a half
minutes about the length which is so
good you know it's 7 50. it could be an
hour
late start here but that's okay you know
we're on
it's if it's eight o'clock here it's
it's 11 o'clock in new york city and
there were probably some good meetings
happening backstage that you know drug
out the process yeah so if you're in
florida right now where you live if
you're in mar-a-lago west palm beach
jupiter
it's 11 o'clock at night i'm sorry folks
you're not getting to bed until saturday
morning because this is going to go at
least an hour and a half oh music faces
step aside ladies and gentlemen please
welcome the 45th president of the united
states president donald
j
trump
at least
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Applause]
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york too
where there's pride in every american
heart and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
the men who died who
[Applause]
i gave stand up next to you and defend
her still today
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you very much and a very very big
hello to an incredible place it's called
arizona thank you
it's great to be back in this beautiful
state with thousands of proud
hard-working american patriots which is
what you are four months from now the
people of arizona are going to fire the
radical left democrats
you are going to elect a truly great
woman who i've gotten to know
very well
terry lake as your next governor
you're going to send a brilliant guy
who i have also gotten to know very well
blake masters to the u.s senate
you're going to elect an incredible
slate of america first republicans up
and down the ballot and we are going to
end crazy nancy pelosi she is crazy
her political career once and for all
ended
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done to our
country in less than two short years
[Applause]
the contrast between the trump
administration's amazing success and joe
biden's breathtaking failure could not
be more stark you see it right here in
your state you see
hundreds of thousands of people pouring
into your state hundreds of thousands of
people
and they have no intention of stopping
it
it's not even believable let's look at
some of the facts less than two years
ago when i was in office
gas gasoline everything called gasoline
now nobody wants to even talk about it
was
1.87 cents a gallon
and now it's five
six
seven and even in some places eight and
nine dollars a gallon
only gonna get worse
we gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation cuts in american history even
larger than the reagan tax cuts that
once held the record by a lot actually
the radical democrats intend to impose
the largest tax hike in american history
that's what they want to do
they think raising taxes is a wonderful
thing so they can waste it on things
like the green new deal
you know what that is
in 300 years from now the ocean will be
one-eighth of an inch higher according
to that
now maybe lower too who the hell knows
right who knows
and they're working feverishly to pile
on more regulations at levels never seen
before nobody's ever seen anything
like what they're trying to do
under the trump administration we had
the greatest economy in the history of
the world with no inflation
no inflation
biden created the worst inflation in 47
years worth 9.1
but the actual number is much
much higher than that and it's going
higher and higher
all the time it's costing families
nearly six thousand dollars a year
bigger than any tax increase ever
proposed other than the tax increase
that they want to propose right now
good luck with that
we created seven million new jobs with
the lowest unemployment rates for
american
and we had the best rates ever we had
the lowest rates
unemployment for americans and for
african americans we had the best
numbers and for hispanic americans we
had the best numbers and for
asian americans
we had the best numbers ever in recorded
history
we had the best numbers for every group
women
men
high school diploma no diploma mit
diplomas
doctors we had the best numbers for
every group there wasn't one group
one group that had worse numbers than
what they had nobody's ever done
anything like it and we were beating
china so badly
so badly
we had a record
164 million people working far more than
we have today we achieved the largest
poverty reduction in 50 years we lifted
seven million people off of food stamps
and we lifted 10 million people off of
welfare 10 million people off of welfare
and they were happy
because they got a great job and they
were making more money than they'd ever
seen before
under biden there are still four million
people who have not returned to the
labor force
real wages are collapsing and we're on
the verge of a
devastating and this is devastating it's
called stagflation look it up it's not
good
it's not good and what i'm concerned
about they keep talking about
having some reversals i don't want
people mentioning the word
depression because where we're going now
could be a very bad place we got to get
this act in order we have to get this
country going or we're going to have a
serious problem not recession
not recession recession's a nice word
we're going to have a much bigger
problem than recession we'll have a deep
pressure
you know in 1929 they had a thing called
the depression you know that right
you wish they wish they could have had a
recession only
i rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability and creation of space
force space force
not since the air force 80 years ago had
anything taken place like space force
and we're lucky we have it and a lot of
it comes out of the state of arizona you
know that right a lot of it
a lot of it a lot of it's here
they surrendered our strength and turned
afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever seen
and not the fact that we were leaving
because i was getting him way down i had
us down to a number that we hadn't seen
in many many years but the way we were
leaving a total surrender we created
the safest border think of it
we created the safest border
in the history of our country and now we
have
the most unsafe border
in the history of our country and i
believe in the history of the world
because i really believe that no country
a third world country doesn't have a
border like we have there's never been
anything like it and you're talking
about millions and millions of people
coming in
unvetted coming in from jails from 141
different countries what they're doing
to our country is ruining it they're
poisoning our country
we ended catch and release we deported
record numbers of illegal aliens and
gang members
and we built hundreds of miles of border
wall
in fact we completely finished our
original plan
despite two and a half years of democrat
inspired lawsuits they sued me from day
one on the wall
two and a half years in court we won
every one of them
we finished the wall and then
we added much more we added a lot of
additional wall they said we could use
some wall over here remember they said
walls don't work walls and wheels i used
to say right
you know they have all sorts of
computers and technology
two things that always happen a wall and
a wheel they're never going to be
replaced i don't think
i don't know when you find something
better than a wheel let me know please
three weeks was all they would have
taken to complete the remaining portion
of the wall we had
we had this thing going like nobody's
ever seen it it had a huge impact and i
want to thank the president of mexico he
gave us 28 000 soldiers free of charge
right 28 000 soldiers
free of charge
and we had a great relationship on the
border with mexico for the first time
now you see what's happened that whole
relationship is gone and people are
flooding us never happened like this
never nothing like this has ever
happened and i said to mexico we need
your help we need your people on the
border they can't come into our country
and they said no i'm sorry we can't do
that i said good that i'm gonna charge
you 25 tariffs
on all of the
things that you make including cars that
are pouring into our country
and they said
on the other hand they said we would
love to help you we would really love to
do it so they gave us 28 000 soldiers
they were great actually they did a very
very good job with the best numbers
we've ever had the border was the best
and the safest in
u.s history and they've turned it into
the worst in u.s history maybe of any
country so i mean think of it and
instead of being proudly energy
independent which we were
just two years ago we were energy
independent we were even energy dominant
the united states is now a beggar for
energy
we're a beggar
for energy
it's crazy
it's crazy think of it
energy the border afghanistan the way we
got out
do you know in afghanistan
i spoke to abdul the leader of the
taliban
and i said abdul you can't kill our
people anymore you kill our people we're
going to hit you so hard you can't do it
abdul and you know what
[Applause]
and actually biden acknowledged this i
didn't think he realized it to be honest
i was very impressed
but 18 months not one american soldier
was killed
and then they
did a surrender
[Applause]
and then the united states did a
surrender leaving all of that equipment
leaving many american citizens behind
right now you have many people living in
afghanistan that don't want to be there
and who knows what's even happening to
them
and think of all of those soldiers that
were hurt killed we lost 13 but some
were horrifically injured no legs no
arms
and worse
you've never seen anything like it and
uh
we had it just where we wanted it we
could have gotten out with dignity and
strength instead we
did something that was i think in my
opinion the greatest embarrassment that
we've ever had in the history of our
country
biden and the radical left have turned
calm into chaos competence into
incompetence
stability into anarchy
prosperity into poverty and security
into a total catastrophe the election
was rigged and stolen and now our
country is being
systematically destroyed because of it
and i appreciate your state and others
you saw what's going on in wisconsin
with the nursing homes
thousands and thousands and thousands of
crooked votes you saw that right almost
everybody voted almost everybody voted
but historically only a very small
portion voted i guess they voted because
they had such a great enthusiasm for
a person that campaigned from the
basement
but it's nursing homes and many other
things and i have to hand it to the
people of wisconsin and so do you and i
want to hand the people of arizona
because you don't stop
you know what happened
[Applause]
and in many ways and i can say that
truly in your state in many ways the
rhinos are worse than the democrats let
me tell you that
i ran twice i won twice
and did much better the second time than
i did the first getting millions more
votes
in 2020 than we got in 2016.
and likewise getting more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country by far
and now
we may have to do it again
i mean look at
look at what has happened to our country
in less than two years our country is
like a different it's like a different
place it's so sad to see
but first we have to win a historic
victory for the republican party this
november
when we retake congress among our
highest priorities must be
to end the nightmare joe biden has
created on our southern border
and your governor doug ducey has done
absolutely nothing to help
talk about rhinos
he's all talk and no action and you'll
see what can happen when kerry lake
becomes your governor
it'll be like day and night
it'll be like day and night it will and
she'll get it done quickly she knows
what has to be done and she's tough and
smart and a very good person this year
alone right here in arizona border
patrol has reported
732 percent increase you believe there's
seven not a hundred not fifteen not
twenty a seven hundred and this comes
from border patrol who are great people
by the way brandon we love you brandon
great people
and ice
would anybody here like a job in ice
where you walk into an ms-13
gaggle
they call it a gaggle you walk into a
group of people ms-13
and they love knives you know they like
knives much better than guns because a
knife kills you slower
and it inflicts great pain
and they've used them many times to kill
people and ice will walk in there and
they'll walk in swinging and i know some
of the people on the first row some of
you are actually mentally tough
but you know what
a couple of you are very financially
tough
you're not going to be a nice i tell you
right now these guys are really patriots
they're incredible people
and they get
not they don't get they get it from the
people but the media is so unfair to
them and the
radical left
a radical left without them you wouldn't
even have a country without ice and the
border patrol and the police that police
defund how about defund the police
think of it
they want open borders they want no
voter id
they want to defund the police
they don't believe in god they don't
believe in oil
they don't believe in the second
amendment and then they're supposed to
win elections i don't think so
i don't think so border patrol is
reported a
732 percent increase in illegal
crossings at your border compared to
when i ran it which is 2020. we had
numbers the likes of which in the low
side and that included drugs and human
trafficking hadn't been so low in 34
years
including over 19 000 unaccompanied
minor youth being dumped by coyotes and
smugglers with no parents or no
supervision just dumped on our land
it's a humanitarian and national
security disaster and it has to be
stopped and it has to be stopped
quickly
every day criminals murderers and sexual
predators are pouring across our border
and ending up
right here congratulations in the state
of arizona right in your
your wonderful arizona
wasn't supposed to be like that nobody's
ever seen anything like it other
countries
are emptying out their prisons and
sending the worst criminals the world
has ever known right into the
united states last month
141 different countries were represented
by people coming in can you imagine most
people don't even know we have 141
countries on this planet
we actually have a lot more than that
but we have 141 countries represented
last month
recently